you're like already sweating today two
days already sweating yeah five seconds
into the podcast you know we should get
sponsored by oh the world's most silent
fan you can put it in the corner of the
room get the air flowing and you won't
hear it I know we've had some reason we
trying to tell Julian because he's
convinced that those Dyson bladeless
fans may not know something like those
maybe I have annoys though if you have a
company in mind that makes a fan with
zero noise that moves air magic picked
up by like decent mics will buy it and
maybe be sponsored by the podcast
unofficially or whatever this podcast
though it's not sponsored by my
imaginary fan it is sponsored by me
undies see Andy's the undies make some
of the most comfortable underwear you
can put on your bottom and they deliver
right to your house check it out at me
undies dot-com that's ME undies calm and
you get 20% off your first order because
we wear me undies oh my god in the
podcast as a whole wears me undies like
if there were me and he's big enough for
this podcast sale there would be me
undies on it'd be covered in undies me
undies calm / Jenna Julian for 20% they
gave us those pants recently though I
have not taken those pants off until
like now seriously we can we can do a
little little um little breakdown on
those pants later where you say about
that okay yeah we'll do it later
yeah how are you guys doing you look you
look like a camera you guys look great
today wow no I was gonna say about me on
these they were in lil Dickies music
video at the end
meet me enjoyable we were all Margaret
if you haven't seen save that money by
lil Dicky it is absolutely worth a watch
wonderful videos one of my favorite
things that's ever existed on the
Internet yeah and he's one of this
possible sponsors and also for those of
you that are fans of the show survivor
the guy fetus was on its second chances
so they're all previous cast members
Larry
spoiler was wearing yeah he's that the
same time yes completely recognized it's
like the distinct me Andy's right yeah
I'm like he's wearing me on B's yeah he
wore me undies on Survivor
that's how legit me undies are no
surviving men exactly Thank You Man DS
for sponsoring us yes they check them
out if you want comfortable underwear um
well what are you doing today Jenna um
well I wanted to play a game because you
know I like to mix up the podcast a
little bit sometimes you have a guest
sometimes we talk about serious topics
sometimes we talk about funny topics and
sometimes we sit here and try and make
each other laugh and I'm always a fan of
those because I'm selfish
correct I'm the most selfish person I
know I'm the only person I know anyways
but I thought it would be funny there
are some apps I've tried to look up
because with grace on her show
I played the Urban Dictionary game where
you basically have someone tell you in
urban dictionary definition and then you
write out what you think it means got it
um unfortunately we don't have like a
third person to do that for us today so
I was looking in the App Store to see
what else existed that we could mess
around with and there's there's these
apps that we never looked up with chat
is by the way is it like Czech Republic
how do you spell it because it might be
check it CH 80 but anyways so I found
these other apps they're all free and
they're called Aussie slang British
slang chat slang us a sleighing food
slang weird words that are in English
and also some riddles slash brain
teasers and I thought maybe we could go
through them and see if we knew any of
them or if we could come up with better
definitions for them sounds good you
know yeah let's do that
especially since we've both been to
Australia together several times yeah
and British slang I mean I'm not really
familiar with
yeah trap slang I think we're both gonna
[ __ ] bomb this jet see tha T all I'm
getting is like chatrooms when I go okay
yeah maybe that's what that means maybe
it has to be that I thought it was like
a shortening of a country and I felt
stupid there's a word for for a Czech
language I know the word I just forget
it just check is it know there's maybe
there's just check you speak Czech I
don't know something like that people
well we're we're in America so oh my god
ignorant selfish America maybe I think
that does make sense
chat language like you're texting yeah
like yeah Internet so basically the app
was made by a person who's in their late
40s who doesn't know yeah but if you
that's that's what they're called if you
want it this is not sponsored by them
obviously but like if you want it to
play you're in a car or something and
you want to play something fun and fast
and easy the I mean let's just [ __ ]
do it
it's it looks fun and I also think it'd
be funny to do us a sling yeah we'll do
all that let's do it
which one do you want to start with um
you Peck you spit you pick the first one
Aziz Lacaze sign well you know worry we
have our own easy oh no work us
ya know what you're gonna say it and
we'll both guess it yeah it literally
means no worries no woke us right no but
the word says no worries so what is in
the answer is the answer is no problem
at all
[ __ ] we're all for one what do you mean
you totally get you know what no worries
means no worries is the word Oh got it
sorry you said no what goods no work
okay so one more Ozzie than no worries
alright alright how about give it a burl
give it a try well yeah it has to be
either that or like a stir like you say
you're cooking something give it a burl
give it a both be URL girl and give it a
try try it try it you're right okay good
day that's too easy
good morning yeah like hello vit hello
how are you hello semicolon
how are you we just agreed in with gala
GA lah [ __ ] gala gah-la garlic well it's
Hal egg backwards
that doesn't help anyone mm maybe it
means you're wasted what could [ __ ]
gala right now I think angry angry huh a
foolish person is a gala oh it's a sin
now like a bellend a bellend oh there
you go love balance a gala so they're
being a real [ __ ] gala me either
although she she misleads me sometimes
like she told me that everyone knows
like what a Shazz is like a you know and
people worry yeah like it's short for
Sharon so they'll take like our sherry
so they'll take Larry or Barry and
they'll call him less lesser Fez basser
yeah and then she's like yeah you never
heard of that like no she was yes sherry
is or Sharon is like a Shazz and that
also means like you're kind of being a
[ __ ] stick in the mud really they're
trying to use whatever you see the real
good yes sick [ __ ] is a great thing I
promise you a sick [ __ ] will not be on
this vocabulary but know about so so
like your own misleads me well I think
it also has to do with a group of like
the age group of person yeah you're
talking to younger people cheer like you
know like younger like YouTube age kid
chill and so they didn't know it maybe
people you know in their 30s would know
it yeah no I just really I love that one
you because appellant Balan is literally
like the head of a penis yeah a bell end
like that they're describing the shape
of a penis and calling you that and you
that's what you call someone when
they're because not only Australian oh
I've heard that when I watched Geordie
Shore yeah bellend I like saying it
about myself no I'm such a bellend
anyways alright next cut lunch just skip
lunch right yeah you they're not are you
talking about like deli meat oh [ __ ]
lunch okay that's what we have our
guesses in minds deli meat your system
lunch sandwiches lunch like it's a cut
that makes sense yeah what if you don't
like your sandwich cut though why would
they just say sandwiches I don't know
cut lunch so much fur fee is that he say
that if you are PHY furphy furphy I
think that's what you like a like a
synonym for like frumpy what does that
mean
front be like you know if you're wearing
your sweatpants and you're like you look
real frumpy fur feel like homely for ya
okay but he got really what do you got
to in or just make one up when you fart
and burp at the same time I fart feet
no like tired so tired to the point
where you get energy like overtired
that's what first burfi a rumor oh you
started a furphy genovese about me no I
like that when you fart any burp and
you're like gassy everywhere you're
furphy well maybe you do that while you
start fer fees for fees it's like a
burpee farty Furby oh yeah like a view
burp and fart while you're doing burped
know if you fart well you do a burpee
you fart what I do a breath I know Anna
furbies in the corner laughing at you
did you ever have a very other creepy
Ozzy come on Miriam yeah Australian okay
rellies are e ll I guess rallies okay I
think it means condiments oh that makes
sense
like relish from ketchup and mustard I
think okay I'm gonna go with their
high-heeled jellies which are shoes okay
did you ever you know what jellies I I
never wore them but I do know what they
are yeah they're hideous and they give
you blisters not like they were the rage
high-heeled jellies come on answer
relatives rallies Road rallies I like
that I want to use that I my rallies are
in town this weekend let's leave my dogs
are my rallies yeah
rallies mmm either make something Kermit
actual rallies cuz they're related yeah
they are they have the same blood gross
inbreeding guys it's real you just been
humping Kermit lately like what yeah
it's just dominance on sexual gee ' a RN
darn darn okay oh I know I know oh maybe
so g'day means like good morning hello
how are you gonna heart my tits like
good our Volvo but then why wouldn't it
be good ARF because for those of you
that don't know what arvo means it means
afternoon well maybe just arvo doesn't
go next to good like maybe Garbo just so
so I think you're right it's good
afternoon like it yeah yeah well I think
it's funny when Rome and I first started
working together she texted me like you
know right when we started and she was
like I'm gonna call you this arvo and it
was like nine in the morning and I was
like [ __ ] I forgot if arvo means morning
or what is Arvin oh yeah for some reason
people tweet at me sometimes asking me
what is our bow afternoon yeah it's
afternoon good arm means you're kidding
it means you're kidding so if I'm like
Jenna Garn I am pregnant and you're like
gone way good guy you can get on okay
clearly logic isn't gonna apply to it oh
yeah I guess it just really makes sense
though yeah I don't know all right
what's the next darn come on man oh we
got an ad okay do you bond it like a hat
that's a bonnet for us though okay so
maybe it's a girl what do you go in a
sundress a sundress yeah that's lovely a
bonnet is the hood of a car Wow
at least I was close my actually my car
gives ahead your car
[ __ ] the hood of hot that's weird on
it if you're Australian and these are
wrong let us know please yeah let us
know I don't know because we're just
trusting this out Bogg in two separate
words vog bog in ah that means
like I'm staying in tonight I'm gonna
bog in that makes sense no I'm probably
doesn't put fog in I think okay I'm just
gonna go with it means you're gonna take
a [ __ ] bath okay bog enough to start
eating ravenously Oh like I'm about a
bog in right now that is a very
applicable slang for you Julian I always
bargain
you never bog not bogging I only bog I
don't always bog but when I do I begin
no I never well yeah that's when you
poop ravenous oh my god bog in like town
I can write I can relate relatable are
you use that one I'm gonna try to about
to bog in with my rallies yo hopefully
room doesn't watch this podcast the next
time we see her we're just like really
good at Australia the [ __ ] lift
oh that's elevator yep right yep that is
an elevator elevator oh man we knew it a
lift is Boozer a bar was a boozer we're
just a drunk person I would think the
wrong person but that's Boozer here I
would say bottle of bottle of booze like
an echo grab a boozer yeah like a booze
a pub like a bar yeah bar okay that
makes sense it's pretty easy grog that's
beer isn't it I don't know what's your
guess
my guess is beard a grog I'm tired
liquor oh god yeah nothing wrong I think
they call that in Harry Potter - raagh
yeah grog or some of it some not all of
it hit your kick okay what the [ __ ] hit
your kick your kick okay I'm just gonna
go with oh I'm gonna stop by your party
like I'm gonna hit your kick your kick
back or whatever I'm gonna hit it I'm
gonna come by okay
kick okay come by your part okay yeah
I'm gonna say it's like feeling good
about that one when you're when you're a
cheerleader you [ __ ] you hit your
visit you hit that kick conjugal kick
side kick on the side that dude [ __ ]
yeah open your wallet oh my god what
does that okay hit your kick this is so
wait so who would who would be saying
open your wallet your kick yeah give me
all your money hit your Chamberland I
need to go bargain oh my god I got what
bargain bargain Eagle bargain thing it
does another thing that have slang for
the words open your wallet I've got to
hit my kid when when in conversation do
you say open your wallet except when
you're robbing someone or if you're
forcing your mom to pay the bill I don't
know man but whoever is saying that you
seem like you see what if it's like okay
what if it's like you get the tab hey
you kick you know still that's like
you're telling someone to pay good oil
what's good oil they have chemistry like
they have good oil mmm we're bonding
well I'm just gonna say a hair spray
because who the [ __ ] knows man useful
information select the oils for your
brain good oil oh my god liquid laughs
what's liquid laughs Julian Paul we
should switch to a different one after
this yeah okay liquid laughs alcohol duh
I'm gonna say throw-ups shots Oh liquid
laughs okay mines throw up yeah Mike
laughing okay I don't know what that's
true but they also like Rome told us
that when they say they're you're
praying to the porcelain God no doubt
one it's like you can't it's porcelain
yeah porcelain throne or something I
think it's praying to the porcelain God
yeah I like that one all right let's
yeah British slang dapper handsome Rick
yeah I'm going with that to well-dressed
are well-spoken him boom nailed it peace
is that like
either your pipe or like your girlfriend
like bi easy easy mom or it could be
your car I don't know your outfit a
packed lunch
what so like when you go to work you
bring a piece I mean I guess can you
grab my piece out of the fridge like it
just sounds [ __ ] wrong
even it's shorter than packed lunch that
jokes I know it's true but then what was
the Australian one for packed lunch
sandwiches Oh cut lunch okay yeah peace
makes me super yeah [ __ ] oh my god
boiler what's a boiler
what's a boiler all I can think of one
of your boiler is like the boiler room
like that's the joke that you say it's a
person who has like I got anger issues
like somebody gets really mad yeah say
like eat the joke is like the special ed
classes or like the other room that's
all I can think of an unattractive woman
huh oh she's a real Tyler boiler quit
bringing boilers home oh my god I feel
like I'm on Geordie smell oh that one's
got funny though if you said that as
like a grenade yeah yeah she's a real
boiler you should real boil it bugger
bugger person like friend human I'm
gonna say it's like a like a [ __ ] okay
like a like [ __ ] that guy he's a really
but like an annoying person yeah [ __ ]
burger thanks oh my god I don't I don't
know how accurate that is this app just
went [ __ ] zero - no chill really wet
sex okay it has that mortal then write
more get more or strappy as we know PPI
stroppy like poorly dressed hmm I'm
gonna go with no that makes sense I
guess stroppy I'm gonna go with uh I
don't know I'm in we're hitting the town
why are you looking so stroppy we're
trying to get more
say maybe like sad sad unreasonable okay
there's so many words stuff death didn't
designated ugly fat friend is that the
movie yeah don't stuff
what is it Duff doesn't need ugly fat
friend that's all you think about it
alright I'm going with that - useless
crap look at all this Duff got a room
full of [ __ ] Duff over here well I'm
always blabbering on to me about some
Duff yeah I don't need to hear this I'm
trying to get more peach all your toys
that you destroy and then leave in the
yard are absolutely absolute off you're
creating Duff Duff Duff forever sharpest
turbo CH a r-va sharp ax Charbagh or
sharp ax I'm looking like a
conversational skill like you have game
I'm gonna say like it's Archie
it's your energy your Chava a child no
no I'm gonna get mortal and have a Chavo
tonight oh maybe I'll make some Chavez
probably insane he's right well [ __ ] it
grass marijuana marijuana
what's grass a snitch or Informer what
the [ __ ] kind of language are you guys
speaking over there how is it grass a
person chat up like talk talk to a girl
like John I agree learn to flirt yes yes
now that we got one yeah oh my god got
one dish shoved dish shift like rejected
by a chick dish shoved whatever whoever
you're talking to say like you
disheveled unhappy well I'm not wrong
yeah we both got the word dis yeah dis
is right trampy I'm gonna say like
[ __ ] or skanky here that's what they
want you to say though trampy trampoline
I want to go with trample trampy it's
disgusting
trapeze disgusting basically well you
look at he's low you're not disgusting
you're like you're looking trappy
tonight
you're looking disgusting but because I
like a good disgusting I don't know
trampy all right what's nicely biscuit I
don't know but if I get hit swinging on
a big [ __ ] I don't know man I'm
[ __ ] on your whole life
my guess is it means a baked good of
some sort I'm gonna say it's like your
money your biscuit no no no this is your
girlfriend who you're you bet your piece
yeah a cookie whose clothes for the
first time [ __ ]
of course it's a cookie frustrating all
right
solicitor is a solicitor no like a
patron of a bar like a patron of a
business a lawyer a lawyer it's like how
in Australia they call a pharmacy a
chemist yeah and then romasaa all
accounts I go wrong well then what do
you call a chemist she goes Candace okay
so a solicitor is a lawyer that's kind
of like a shitty you like yeah cuz
solicitors are usually something back to
the door salesman right yeah bollocks
like [ __ ] Oh bollocks yeah yeah like a
button on Fox not buttons Oh testicles
okay well I guess well that's nice we've
been saying testicles yeah
bollocks like chefs I use in a sentence
yeah like I hit my molix [ __ ] no it's
being man if you want your bollocks to
be comfortable go to me and ease calm so
you will have the most comfortable
experience with nice calm has awesome
designs but really really soft watch out
phone saying really really soft material
it's twice twice as half it's cotton
please what's the [ __ ] man so let's talk
about okay so they sent us these pants
these are the new pants they're
basically their underwear but in pants
form and it's like they're not sweat
pants are very thin they're like
underwear thin but they're pants you
wear around the house and let me tell
you like I've never put on anything as
comfortable as that like I was I was
like confused like I felt like dirty
like like I was like this is not yeah I
feel too comfortable right now yeah no
Julian got them he opened the package
for the Andes and he goes look at these
pants they sent us I'm like all it's so
cool
stairs I'll take a turn I was like okay
I put mine on she was like let me feel
them oh wait I want Susan I immediately
put mine on and then didn't take them
off oh my god sir since I've had this
this is their new line of pants but they
have a whole entire line of underwear
for both men and women like great great
stuff if you're in need of underwear and
you don't feel like going to the store
or a mall to buy underwear they deliver
it to your front door that's hard too
because me undies calm slash Jenna
Julian 20 percent off your first order
so if you're gonna spend a hundred bucks
on underwear you use our code and you
get 20 bucks off yeah that's two so I
can easily spend $100 on underwear
because peach because peach choose her
underwear so me and he's literally
making Jenna like have underwear at all
thank you me and ease check them out if
you guys get some me undies do not send
us a picture of you wearing them that's
inappropriate but let us know if you
like them pretty guarantees all right
let's move on to chat sling that slang
so this is we're assuming this is online
that ruse right well the first one is
guys SOS yeah ASO like save our souls
yeah like help help same old [ __ ] oh you
know I [ __ ] knew that one damn it
really damn it I didn't know I mean I
watched on the internet so s really yeah
like in myspace days that's what that
was
MySpace that's what his list was made
this in happen for some reason exists
now but okay that's nice
see like a [ __ ] I live on the
internet and I don't know like chat okay
there's the less than sign W and then
the greater is nine so it's like this
with a W in between I don't know is that
like coding that's not it means like I'm
mad at you like cuz it looks like
someone going like that I think it just
means we're okay we're yeah
it means wink what's the phone my god
get an emoji
oh god this is gonna be bad oh this
one's infuriating ti a il T ia IL it's
gotta be an aqueduct is that TL
today I am in love I'm just gonna go
with [ __ ] like your girlfriend she's
like TL ya my [ __ ] tail I think I am
in love that's [ __ ] right really
that's not even an acronym iti ail
that's what it should be but it's just
tea I think I'm in love
okay well I was close so a good point
since we're totally peeps peeps people
friends yeah people or just those things
you eat on Easterns other people people
have you heard about that new app by the
way people PE ple nope so it's basically
like a Yelp or whatever but you review
people that's amazing people are
freaking out about it
apparently cuz I watched Philip
defranco's show I watching my baby I
have four years but he said that you
need someone's phone number in order to
review them so it's not straight look
and just go on there and you know that's
like who can you review okay and the
backlash has been that like okay this
can turn into like bullying really quick
really like what the [ __ ] um and people
it's not out yet but they're like oh no
once you get a review you have 48 hours
like tells you it notifies you so that
you can't this is their reasoning so
that you can reach out to the person and
see maybe why they left you a negative
review oh my god that's so weird isn't
it it's just weird I don't like that huh
makes it feel weird well I mean we've
imagined so you know you put yourself
out there but I put myself out there a
fair amount imagine the people that are
not really they don't really want to be
out there I don't want to know what
people are saying about me it's the
opposite of what like I'm into about the
internet like like you said you if
someone has a [ __ ] problem to you
they're gonna say it oh they're gonna
come at me like you look gross you know
I mean cuz you're anonymous enough on
the Internet to where like you don't
have to review someone and like leave it
on a forum it's like a [ __ ] talking
forum basically yeah no I told you go to
one place to leave all of your
[ __ ] that you would not say because
you're obviously you're not gonna review
them positively otherwise you just say
that to them right well I imagine it
might start off as like everyone be like
oh this is my friend this is my mom like
please don't sit here and talk [ __ ] I
want to know though I want it because I
think it's a little bit fascinating
right that you're you you created this
there's no reason legally why they can't
create it I don't think if I were people
I wouldn't want that blood on my hands
you know what I mean like someone
becoming really sorry we're going in a
tangent but someone who got really upset
by a people review and then you know now
me as a company I'm like what if I
created this is a [ __ ] mess well you
I mean you have to have anticipated that
of your people like if you're the person
who made this app you like you honestly
hope for that can that fix your app up
well yeah but I think they made it that
way and then they're standing by it as
it just being like useful to review
people for long
yeah I think that it was created to be
like a [ __ ] talk yeah have you ever
heard of I don't even know if anyone
uses it but it was an app like a few
years ago but it was for dudes where
girls could go on and rate their
ex-boyfriends basically I heard about
that and I don't know exactly what it
was but it was called either but like is
that what we have become like we're not
really just rating people the last time
I rated a person was like you know in
seventh grade when we passed her on the
notebook like the early days of Facebook
yeah and we know we would literally pass
each other a notebook with like a list
of all the boys in our class and we
would read them on like their
personality and stuff and like it was
Ned serious this oh okay I was like this
isn't part of the gossip you know yeah
yeah so like if they're really athletic
we'd give them like extra points or like
if they're really smart yeah no matter
what the PR of that people app is they a
hundred percent created it with that
malicious intent yeah but like we I
thought the last time I've ever done
that and the only time I've ever done
that was on it was an actual like child
and the boys would never see it no they
destro
we mostly use it to figure out who each
other liked so that we didn't like the
same boy it was never meant to be like
your your rating someone which is very
clearing her well because if there was
someone that we weren't interested in we
just wouldn't rate them we wouldn't let
go in there and be mean yeah like it was
like it just a you know 11 year old girl
spreadsheet so weird to make sure you
didn't have the same crushes no right
yeah like I'm just trying to I'm trying
to like wrap my brain around but I think
the the one for like boyfriends and [ __ ]
like people would get on there
and they're either like really kind of
gross and creepy or they're like you
know clearly one girl just like going
the [ __ ] off cuz here's the thing I mean
in an in a utopia in an ideal place in
world and with with people who don't act
like [ __ ] that people are you can go
and think to yourself yes I'm gonna wake
up this morning and check my people
profile I'm going to check the profile
where people are allowed to and honestly
anonymously say things about me and I'm
gonna look at it I'm gonna say okay this
makes sense I'm gonna better myself I'm
gonna take these notes and move on like
ideally yeah I get it
the concept but it's so not practical
because people wouldn't use it in that
vein they would 100% use it to trash
someone that they didn't want to be able
to say it to their face and so you're
left with waking up and looking at this
stuff like okay this is basically just
hate mail and I don't know who it's from
I don't know if it's real or validated
or if it's just like pure hate and
making me want you know making me feel
bad on purpose like you know there's no
distinguishing yeah that that's the
important part about the Internet is
that yeah we do have anonymity like we
can be who are to an extent right but if
you're going to be on you know Facebook
or Twitter like you can to some extent
control who sees what you write and who
can follow you who can't be your friend
like dude I mean you have control over
some of that stuff and to sort of take
that away and just be like well anybody
that has your phone number can go write
some [ __ ] who is that helping it's not
helping anyone
no it's it's it's encouraging the wrong
way to go about having a problem with
someone
you know like it's like I don't know how
else to say it it's basically just a way
to constructively talk [ __ ] yeah it's
it's a forum for that $0.19 I think it's
interesting I will totally download it
when it comes out I I don't feel you
know maybe this is me in hindsight
having [ __ ] 20/20 vision but I don't
feel the need to go through my phone
book and write some reviews about people
nor do I think that people feel strongly
about me enough to write some [ __ ]
[ __ ] people have my phone number you
know what my mom's gonna go on there and
be like hey Jenna you know I can and the
whole idea of social media is that
you're being social this is anti social
media yeah like this is a way to
communicate in the most non human and
non social way possible yeah and I mean
they're they're calling it you know the
Yelp of people no but that's wrong
that's a bad comparison I get but think
about it in theory like it they're
saying you know people make such an
impact in your life like would it be
helpful if you knew some things about
them before you got involved with them
but I just totally disagree you know so
now you have like a description like
you're an item on a website right
you're not app like this you're just
you're a person on paper god this is
scary I don't like this if you're a
person who makes people feel good about
themselves and you inflict positive
positivity on others in your life and
who you ever interact with and you know
you you conduct yourself like that the
people who you come in contact with in
your life will feel that way they're
going to feel good you mean think about
it right now everyone listening like
there are those people in your life that
you know and you hang out with and you
see and you remember how you feel when
you're with them and when they make you
feel good that's that's a person who is
genuinely to the core a nice person
because they there's they they show
interest in you and they do something to
make you feel like happy so you're left
with the feeling of how you feel when
you're with a person that a hundred
percent not only should be the way that
a person is rated or or judged and
and talked about by others and not them
but it's a it's that's the only real way
it works like you can't write and sit on
a phone yeah and type what you know no I
think we're trying to say is that it's
completely completely 100% subjective
from person to person yeah there's a
reason why you know you and I might date
rather than you date someone and I date
someone else because we get along so
well like you're not gonna hit it off
with every single person ever you're not
gonna get along with every single person
ever I it's a little bit confusing that
anyone would read a review about someone
else and then make an assumption based
exactly yes because you're just as
guilty as the person who wrote the
review right well yeah you're not
getting to know the person from your
perspective you're just doing it someone
else's you're cheating everyone in the
way which is what like Yelp is helpful
yeah because you're trying to you know
maybe get a good dinner problem with the
output yes hundred percent problems with
Yelp you're trying to get a good service
but again it's completely when high
percents objectives how do you read the
bad reviews on Yelp like some of the
ones that people dig up they make me cry
laughing like these people are so angry
and so furious about like a particular
CVS or grocery store and you're like
dude it's really not that bad I've
written one review on Yelp and you were
there for it do you remember yeah it was
it was lengthy it was likely are we are
New York and this place claimed to have
gluten-free pizza and I got delivered on
it was bad it was like like probably ten
times worse than it would have tasted if
I just ate cardboard honestly it was a
horrible and and like they were I don't
know whatever but yeah when you get into
like when you have a problem with a
place and you have bad customer service
of course you want to like vent on a
forum where you know people are gonna
see it that's what Yelp is good way up
as bad as like it's corrupt sometimes
you know it's I can't quote what exactly
the theory is but like when when you
have a good experience
you'll tell maybe one or two people of
your friends like word of mouth yeah but
if you have a bad experience you'll tell
like 10 to tell all your tell everybody
drink a glass of wine
and tell everyone that was not my joke
that was our grace to jump from the
streamys remember I only leave like
positive reviews on Yelp for the most
part because I want to support the
business stuff I know that it helps I
love when you get a good experience and
they're like hey could you please maybe
rate us on Yelp record
yeah I wasn't going to but of course I
will like I had a great time but to
circle back I really think that you know
the way you act in the way you make
others feel they will they you know like
people like you who know you personally
and who have met you personally because
they have met you personally so if I'm
someone who hasn't met you and I meet
someone and I'm like yeah yeah I heard
she's a nice girl
and they've met you and they're like oh
she's so sweet she's this she's that I'm
gonna be like well I'm talking to
someone who actually met her of course
I'm gonna take your word that is what I
think of you now until you prove me
otherwise for an app there's no rules
there's no grounding there's no I
there's no way to right you just need
someone's phone up justify anything a
lot of people you could just google
exactly it becomes it becomes very
internet like hiding very fast right and
not helpful weird app I'm glad we kind
of got on that tangent I don't know that
it's a hundred percent weird I mean I
feel like I'll download it and [ __ ]
check it out because why not
I think it's weird I'll check it out to
where them go check it out you know you
oh we should draw some of our friends
and write some really [ __ ] weird ass
reviews well yeah what if it's a
hysterical app we should write some
really funny reviews about our like
friends and then ask them if they've
heard of this app be like guys have you
heard of this app people can rate you
from your phone number and then go on
and then they read these reviews I think
that's a great idea that's like a good
prank actually okay nobody do that
because I want to do it I think I've had
the same phone number for like ever in
it like you have high school people no
yeah I have no idea I occasionally get
prank calls in here I've had the same
phone number
I had a really funny prank call it
wasn't a prank call but like people just
for the record if you do ever find my
phone number or my address like that
that's the line for me like it's not you
really we've had that [ __ ] yeah don't
dare people but you know I'm not gonna
talk to you I'm not gonna text you I'm
not gonna you guys just cuz it's this is
like my house and in my life but
everything else I put on the Internet
but please don't like show up at the
house or call my phone but I did I
answered it because it was from a
blocked number and it was right after we
did that prank calling video for me so I
thought it was Julian and yet forgot
he'd forgotten just shut up yeah yeah
turn on excite you answered it think you
knew it's Julian and it's this kid and
you just cuz haze jennamarbles I go yeah
it is but you probably shouldn't have my
phone number
and he goes oh okay well you know I like
I like looked it up on the internet so
you should be careful and I go alright
thanks man bye
that's like I don't think people think
about what's gonna happen again a hold
of you so he just goes alright well you
better be careful I'm like okay I did
just like clearly look at
eleven-year-old I mean we do everything
in our power to keep all of that type of
information private well tempting for
people no it is but I'm just I'm just
want to piggyback of what you said like
we really put a lot of manpower and
hours into trying to make it so none of
that information is public and yet
sometimes the internet doesn't obey what
you do and the number will get out so we
do really appreciate those of you who
respect the privacy and don't do that
for your own pleasure because you know
we're humans yeah don't do to anybody
it's really really cool but that's what
I'm saying about like your privacy and
your phone number is that like if
someone really wants to find your phone
number they're gonna find it yes and no
but yeah like totally good yes no I've
been hacked some [ __ ] and [ __ ]
figured I don't know so it's like I say
you [ __ ] hated Salma Hayek and you
really just wanted to like lay into her
on people I'm sure you could find her
phone number and [ __ ] do it is that
crazy though it is crazy that the app is
[ __ ] crazy
forty-eight hours in case you want to
make amends with whoever made you angry
what is that like I said they've you get
a notification from people that says
someone has a phone number to write a
review and like would you like to reach
out to them as they reviewed you try to
yeah so guys if you creep on us we'll
have your number too anyways good
tangent do you want to do a couple
American ones sure
Blount we're back just lying it's like a
blunt like a cigar that you rolled weed
in then you smoke it that's why I'm
really honest a cigar filled with
marijuana big stink you like making a
scene you're making a big stink about it
yeah I mean I guess so yeah a serious
issue yeah making it do a big thing
I'm not sure that's like tell my mommy
money say that my mumbo jumbo it's like
garbage no maybe someone's talking to
mumble no yeah that's a bunch of PETA's
peanut gallery gibberish gibberish Oh
like you can't understand it date what's
bait when you're fishing and you go you
take your hook and you put that thing
right you are an unsafe location
okay did Chris Hansen make this app have
a seat yeah I have a seat as it temple
yeah blast Kevin in this is fun yeah I
had a good time having a blast to
confront someone Oh put them right those
words those are important action pure
director and you want to start going oh
fun excitement oh they're talking about
like social having second action okay
these are the action lately head huh
[ __ ] yeah I know but like when did
this app get so sexual Chris Hansen this
is [ __ ] up oral sex Chris Hansen what
a [ __ ] up at app download Chris Hansen
that oh my god right now the more
food slang I don't know any of these a
food slang walk a cow through the garden
what's that slang for like a veggie
burger walk a cow yeah maybe
hamburger with lettuce tomato and onion
cuz you're getting all this oh [ __ ] yeah
walk a cow through yeah that is [ __ ] a
fish is fish guys this is food yeah food
slang um like caviar - eggs no caviar
tapioca pudding weird it is weird
Mississippi mud it's not slang for don't
know no [ __ ] I don't say like bourbon
or some [ __ ] huh some dark liquor talk
lick off mustard Mississippi mud is
mustard rabbit spirits like salad like
anything green lettuce dog in maggot um
sauerkraut on the hotdog maybe I mean
that it's better than anything I'm gonna
come up with cracker and cheese is dog
in Maggie yeah what that's that that
those words don't make me hungry I don't
know why you would write dog in maggot
that makes me angry enough 55 what's a
55 no idea what the [ __ ] I don't know
any of this I'm gonna say it's a 5-hour
energy in a sprite 55 it's gonna it's
okay it's 55 hour energy 50 continue
here to give a glass of root beer no
that's wrong I don't like that smear
it's like something on your face
no it's food yes some say it's like oh
like cream baby's name cheese oh okay
oh that's like schmutz when you say you
have schmutz on you sure what's I knew
for that bagel cream cheese is this
American food er yeah it's just food
slang spider dabs like appetizers
that's pretty good splattered ABS part
of it
I'm gonna go it like plaque up the chips
splatter devs
the pancakes got it right splatter dabs
balloon juice
what the [ __ ] is balloon juice balloon
juice tomato juice maybe I don't know
yeah or apple juice Seltzer or soda
water because there's air in it ah fizzy
lifting drinks that's [ __ ] dumb
[ __ ] dumb nice
[ __ ] you boiled leaves no idea it's tea
oh that makes sense
alright I want to do a riddle can we do
a riddle how's the room okay what are
the coolest letters in the alphabet I
don't know
I'm gonna go Jay yes Jay and Jay yeah
it's AC are we sure these are riddles
not yours yeah how many eggs can you put
in an empty basket known as an empty
basket okay Julian okay do it okay one
after that the basket is not empty your
answer was more right than theirs
alright I am the beginning of the end
and the end of a time and space I am
essential to creation and I surround
every place what am i an atom not air
cuz there's not a hair everywhere yeah
yeah the letter e oh my ok no I quit I'm
done you're gonna rage quitting but this
app is called best riddles can we give
it a bad rating while we're on the
podcast please oh my god that one's
frustrating going into going to the App
Store giving you guys you have to look
at it and read it in order to get angry
about it is this the app yeah that's
real giving it about no no I'm giving it
a better view it sucks no it's kind of
fun write a review how many times can
you subtract the number 5 from 25 as
many as you want I'm gonna say once cuz
then it would be uh yeah that's that's
the answer
stupid oh you must own the app twice
because after you subtract it it's not
25 anymore nice these are like such
smart ass [ __ ] answers man you can
see nothing else when you look in my
face I will look you in the eye and I
will never lie Who am I
a mirror her dog your dog yeah your
reflection you love your reflection if
you are if you're checking yourself out
with some me and these on guys get some
me undies support the me Andes who
support the podcast any unease calm
slots Jenna Jillian 20% off your me
undies we got a me on his hat you got me
anytime and if you're interested check
out I'm not sure if they're out yet but
those pants if you can get your hands on
those go to me Andy's calm and see if
they have them
those are incredible and I will be
wearing them all weekend true I will be
Tim we're doing a last word out let's
see one more okay fine what can burn the
eyes stay in the mouth yet be consumed
an onion jalapeño now it's got to be Oh
either any spicy food jizz is that oh my
god how dare you [ __ ] you wanna have a
cm I stand less blood clots peppers
that's so lame really nice one that
should be dead no weren't less you gotta
end on different one that should be
distribute all dad jokes that are worse
than dad jokes yeah it should be
dad riddles shitty dad jokes so like
your dad is shitty and he's telling
jokes not the jokes okay like bad dad
jokes dad jokes
what kind of coat can only be put on
when wet the paint paint coat yeah yeah
good you feel good about that one you
sure yeah know what flies without wings
air no know what flies without wings a
balloon a bullet when I shoot the guy
who made is that time oh my god I hate
my life okay you can just continue
telling reals
I'm out this time is i socks until I am
measured I am not known yet how you miss
me when I have flown what am i I swear
this is time yes I'm gonna throw it time
they just had two rails are over the
answer time oh I just reminded me why I
hate riddles I hate that oh well I'm
glad that we had rid of you own it so
you need to write about of you I can't
write about view and I say on it and I'm
not owning that it's free I'm not
putting that filth on my phone
okay well okay on a positive now I had a
great conversation with you yeah it was
fun um good podcast podcast thanks guys
for hanging out for the podcast news and
thank you for tuning in guys
don't let us know in the comments about
anything we said we love you here it is
playing especially yeah if you're from
another country tell us your slang or
like how off that slang is yeah cuz it's
off us [ __ ] we love you guys thanks as
always for hanging out yeah bog in its
bog off I'm gonna book this bog off no
bargain but that slang was bogged the
[ __ ] off well then yeah we all get more
all gonna get more tonight more or
someone from George hard to start a new
channel and I'm a loser
oh [ __ ] who is it Charlotte I'm
Charlotte on Instagram for years I
didn't want to reach from know she was
covetous fascinating she is fast and she
knows plays people on the show yes yes
Charlie's Gilmore Oh Oh a competent
video you did do a creep don't you just
started her channel
and I said I'm so excited for this
channel it's gonna be the most mortal
one on YouTube you said no I haven't
just been sitting there refreshing
there's none stop my name is Julie and I
would love to get movin out now you're
making me sound like